joining me today is an entrepreneur the
co-founder of clarity capital and the
author of God in the crowd
21st century Judaism talking and welcome
to the Rubin report thank you Dave
so there's a lot that I want to talk to
you about here because I mentioned you
right before we started that most of the
conversations that I've had here about
religion have come from a Christian
perspective so adding a Jewish element
to this I thought would be interesting
your your story is kind of fascinating
you're a Jew from Florida and yet your
religious awakening was because of a
Christian minister in New England am I
getting that correct yeah that's right
start there so I grew up in boarding
schools mainly in New Hampshire so born
in Florida and grew up there until age
10 but then then New Hampshire and you
know I got into Judaism for what a day
describes the wrong the wrong reasons
I don't you've seen the picture of the
boy in the Warsaw Ghetto with his hands
yeah kind of like that yeah I saw that
when I was 16 years old and immediately
became where I was looking at the
picture wrong you know it's it's it's
framed in a way that almost begs this
juxtaposition between the the boys in a
sense he was six or seven years old and
gellick face and the Nazi barbarism you
can see on the right side of the picture
you've got the Nazis and with their guns
pointed in his in his direction and that
never spoke to me and I tried to muster
anger and hatred for these Nazis I
couldn't all I saw was irrelevance
you know this you know I didn't have a
good sense of Jewish history but enough
of a sense to realize this is that was
just that generations manifestation of
an age-old phenomenon that just keeps
coming back it was in Iraq during the
Farr who'd you know two years earlier it
was with Russian Cossacks you know
thirty years earlier this keeps
happening but if you look at the left
side of the picture and you google it
boy in the Warsaw Ghetto anything's the
first thing that comes out you see the
boy's family and they're being I think
that evacuated from the building this is
the liquidation of the ghetto in 1943
and they're in this state of shocked
submission you see it in their body
language and then and their expressions
and I was furious at them for having
abrogated their responsibilities to this
how could they not have had a
contingency plan there the Jews had they
convinced themselves that they were
polish and here they were about to be
marched off to their deaths as far as I
know everyone in that picture was was
dead and within within weeks but it only
took a week to realize I'm probably as
close as age in age to the parents as I
am to the child
what's my contingency plan and and for
the first time I started thinking of
myself as a Jew and I come from a
typical American all three of my older
brothers married non-jewish women were
we probably pretty much shake out the
way American Judaism does we had no
training I had no familiarity with
Judaism at the time so you didn't grow
up religious in any way right no I guess
not if you were going to boarding school
and in the Northeast right right yeah so
so what happened then you have this wake
up so I so Reverend Thompson was the
school chaplain it was a Exeter it's a
prep school in New Hampshire he was a
Congregationalist minister it's a branch
of Calvinism that was the read kind of
original religion in the Massachusetts
Bay Colony very open very Old Testament
focused and he knew a lot about Judaism
and he arranged a weekly Shabbat dinner
for the for the Jewish kids which I
started going to after that it never
really meant anything to me up until
that that at that moment and got me into
it I don't know if it's exactly religion
but a sort of a spirituality that's tied
to this ritual of Shabbat
a sort of a mode shift and you know from
that point I kind of dug into everything
I could took every class that had to do
with Judaism I read them the Old
Testament I could never became a
believer in the kind of classical sense
in the god of scripture I'm still still
haven't haven't been able to access that
but found my way to Israel through that
yeah and you ended up in the Israeli Air
Force yeah yeah that's quite a jump from
go to face yeah that's right yeah what
was that like we're just doing the
biographical stuff yeah yeah you know it
certainly it wasn't the plan I mean
I came enamored with Zionism on a summer
tour kind of a something like a
birthright type program the summer after
I saw that picture and I fell in love I
think that's the best way to just
describe it you know suspended pretty
much all logic and I think the notion
that got me is this was the opposite of
what I saw in that picture mm-hmm and it
took me until then to realize that that
the the thing that struck me the most
was the lack of dignity in that picture
we had no agency we were just victims
and it was just such a terrible way to
kind of define ourselves and think of
ourselves as a people and you know when
I asked Jewish friends at Exeter or even
my family if you know is there a
contingency plan what do we do my
grandfather was German I think he
conceived of himself when he was you
know my age at the time as German way
before he was Jewish until he was
notified you're no longer German and
luckily that happened in 1936 in 1990 39
so he could still leave what happens if
we get that call what's our what's our
plan and people thought that was a crazy
question yeah well it's just not a
pleasant thing to have to think of it
yeah who talked about that and in Israel
I saw people who had not just asked that
question with all the courage that it
takes to you know you need to muster in
order to ask but they'd answered it and
here was dignity and it was it was
intoxicating to me and so I at that
point I think realized I was gonna make
my way somehow to Israel whether I was
gonna live there or just be very
involved and when I finally did move
you know I understood that military
service was kind of the ticket to full
membership and so I did what I was told
I ended up at but ending up in the Air
Force is not an easy route for that
ticket yeah turns out most complex route
I would imagine yeah was the time was it
was very very complicated and it
certainly wasn't a natural fit for me
and required a lot of a lot of
adjustments along the way but but that
that is where I ended up yeah and and in
kind of what I think brought me to the
book ultimately is that you know I I
found myself it's such and intense
experience you know the Academy is just
extremely it's just a concentrated sort
of knowledge and skills dump and and it
doesn't let up after you you you
graduate that I really never had time to
examine what is this what what what what
exactly am i pursuing what is Judaism
what is Israel I didn't know Israel I
know I knew a very narrow cut you know
kind of the several hundred people whom
the air crew community knows oh that's
my news right that was Israel for me and
it's not reflective of society and you
know it took me probably you know eight
or nine years of service to kind of step
back and say okay now can I have the
time to investigate what this is and
that was actually a moment of crisis
because I had already done things that I
couldn't take back I mean you know
there's a very combat intensive decade
that the 1990s in Israel you know what
what had started sort of as a romantic
so Teach for America or Peace Corps type
type adventure of college kid ended up
being something that I couldn't couldn't
erase there's things I could not take
back and I had to really understand what
it is that I was doing there and I
started kind of a search into what is
Judaism exactly all right so that's a
perfect setup on a personal note for
everything that the book is about that
we're gonna talk about here so first I
was trying to think the right way to do
this interview because it's a little
weird talking about Judaism in a
religious sense because it's an
ethnicity and a culture and a religion
and usually when people are talking
about religion you can remove those two
other things because people are from all
parts of the world and have different
you know traditions and all of that but
Jews have the same traditions and those
are at least at some level related to
religion and all that so what's the
easiest way to start that conversation
about culture and tradition and religion
all all in one mixed bag well that is
very much at the heart of this book is
that we're called upon the generations
of Jews who are alive today are called
upon to redefine Judaism and in what way
I think might kind of the premise I
start with is in our story it's almost a
four thousand years story we have two
episodes of fundamental reinvention
Judaism is constantly evolving we've
always changed there's no generation
that bequeathed the same doodoos with
their kid
that they inherited from their parents
but there were two fundamental
reinventions one is the exodus where we
leave Egypt unclear what we are exactly
or some group but it's unclear exactly
what what it is and 40 years later
arrived in the promised land with
sovereignty right we control ourselves
and we're governed by a book of law
which will stay with us for for as long
as our story laughs and it's still with
us today it's a fundamental
reconfiguration of what this is what
this enterprise is Judaism and the
second is the Roman expulsion from from
Israel in the year 135 which is right
the end of sovereignty in Israel at the
end of a geographic so Jews didn't all
show up there in 1948 that later okay
right now yes we're exactly okay so here
we are a people configured very much
like any other people around us the
Phoenicians and Nabataeans we we look
like any province of the Roman Empire in
in most ways and then off we go are
scattered to hundreds of nodes around
the world with an already complex
orthodoxy that was to continue evolving
dramatically over the next 2,000 years
no central conductor no Pope officiating
over our evolution almost no contact
between most of the notes right if you
were off in some shtetl in Poland and I
was in Casablanca we didn't even know
about each other we certainly were not
in touch with each other for most of
that period what I would have bet
against the idea that the via coherent
identity called Jew 1800 years after
that event it is you know it did
something I think bears investigation
hmm but you think there's a reason for
that and that's what this book is about
I do and I think that was the second
fundamental reinvention where we're not
we reconfigured ourselves at that point
we became a people that was about a set
of questions and debating a set of
questions ethical questions which we
still do today I think we're on the eve
of a third fundamental reinvention and
that comes from the fact or were or at
least the what I posit is that
anti-semitism is no longer a defining
force for the Jews for 1800 years it was
we most for most of that period we
didn't have the choice
to be you know we talk about religion
you know we use the word faith and
religion sort of interchangeably and yet
I did say hey there's not a central
component of Judaism mm-hmm
not in the way we define ourselves not
the way we were defined it no no one
asked you what you believed before
you've stepped into the gas chambers
right that was you could be secular you
could be an atheist you could be what
didn't matter you were a Jew so it
wasn't a related wasn't a faith that
that and I think in that sense the Nazis
got us right in many ways is it's not
not really about whether we believe or
not which is why they're seemingly are
so many Jewish atheist which I can get
into and I think that works and has
worked throughout Jewish history I mean
yeah faith is not a precondition to you
know to Jewish observance even Orthodox
Jewish observance but what we're facing
today I think is is certainly not
precedented than in the last two
thousand years is that ninety percent of
us live in the United States and in
Israel two jurisdictions that I think
are largely devoid of anti-semitism in
in any practical day-to-day way I have
you know a maybe a correction is on on
the left there is something happening
today that I we should maybe talk about
it's a fault in the book I may be too
dismissive of that and I hope it's a
passing you know fad but essentially in
this country being Jewish is a choice
today it wasn't for our grandparents
generation we're Jewish kind of in the
sense that you are in Europe today right
if you're French a French Jew you're a
Jew
I mean to to to to other French people
that that's our were looked at in this
country you are truly an American and in
Israel you are truly Israeli Judaism is
a choice that's our challenge it's a
huge opportunity because for the first
time I think we can write our own script
throughout the Jewish world not just in
Israel we can decide what this is what
is this enterprise but it's also a
threat because right now and if we see
what's happening in this country and
it's much easier to track it in this
country we're voting with our feet we
are marrying ourselves out of existence
which you know the for the first section
of the book scold should there be Jews I
think we have to start with that
fundamental question and ask it honestly
and bravely yeah
so so why is your answer to that
question yes yeah
because I think a certain amount of
people would say
all right well that so I would I was
gonna ask you this at the end but when I
had my first sit-down with Sam Harris
who's who is obviously one of the most
well known atheists but he was born
Jewish I don't think he considers
himself Jewish in a in any real sense
but I don't want to speak for him
specifically we did talk about this this
a couple years ago and he said that
there would be a nice end story to the
Jews which is that they would all give
up on all of the superstition and all
the rest of it and just sort of evolved
out of it and that would be a pleasant
ending that's his basic premise on that
but that's not your premise so I'd love
to hear so why is the answer well for
what I think I would agree with this if
we are gonna end that's the best way to
do it for sure okay this is the dreamer
but but I would say look you I mean when
I get when I look at what Sam Harris has
I think tried to do over time which to
me and I don't know if he'd put it this
way but to me it's very much inventing a
religion that doesn't require faith
right or an ethical system maybe
religion is the wrong word in that you
know there's a lot that's wired in us
from the Savannah right a lot of
altruism altruism and morality that is
wired as let's build on that let's take
the Golden Rule as a sort of a as a
starting point and build on that I like
that I think the issue with it is you
know I used the wisdom of crowds as a as
a sort of as a framework for Joe's
governance in India as breh and I
believe in it I think there is something
quite compelling about this notion of a
group defining itself in governance
governing itself through through crowd
wisdom it's a great kind of noise
cancellation mechanism and this is what
you'd say is sort of the lack of the
top-down part of Judaism cuz there is no
Pope not everybody's or we're not all
pointing one way for this or looking for
wisdom in that direction correct it's
coming from the people yeah it's it
requires diversity it requires
independent thought that that's Jewish
that is one of the issues and you see
this in markets all the time markets at
the end of the day financial markets are
are you know in many ways an exercise in
crowd wisdom we're trying to divine a
truth what is the value of that stock
what is the present value of future
earnings of this company that's what
world
I guess at at its essence and one thing
you'll find is if you look at it
long-term if you look at chart the S&P
500 for the last hundred years all right
you'll see that it's incredible how
closely you know if you look at the
actual present value of future earnings
in retrospective both of the Securities
and that in that in that index you'll
find that the mark is incredibly good at
getting it right over long periods of
time but zoom in on any short timeframe
reverie years five years it's always
wrong almost always wrong the market is
almost always wrong in the short term so
the notion of inventing a code of ethics
from scratch leaves us hostage to the
sensibilities of our generation you know
I often it's a tough question to say but
had I been born a Lutheran in Germany
and come of age in the 1930s can I say I
would definitely would not have joined
the Nazi movement of course not most
people right it's a vulnerable question
to face but I think it's an important
one to think about right we're all
hostage to kind of prevailing winds of
our era what I think Judaism does and
the reason I think it has value not just
to Jews but but to humanity is it is a
methodically recorded history of the
evolution of our ethics as a species
right it's a it's a critically important
reference point and it's a unique
reference point now there's a record of
papal edicts that also goes back a long
way and I think it's also extremely
valuable it's different though right
it's the opinion of one man very learned
men in general but but it's one man what
we have now is a snapshot of the crowd
wisdom of a generation on questions that
you know and judy is always always great
about kind of highlighting the two
tensions right Hillel and Shammai you go
into a wedding you're introduced to the
bride and the people a person introduces
isn't she beautiful and you don't think
she's beautiful what do you say okay so
Shama I will say well the most important
guiding ethic is truth right honesty is
is is a is a is a critical value that we
be pursuing I would come down on the
side of tell the truth no I don't think
you're beautiful
that's a tough one it ready their
wedding will say no humanity is a moor
now understand that honesty I'm giving
it its due for sure I I get your point
however here's where I think the Optima
that's that that is the exercise of
Judaism it has been I think forever but
we've recorded a history the evolution
of the both the consensus views and the
dissenting views on a host of topic that
is tongue would that is that is that
exercise so when we use a term like
justice today mm-hmm justice is not a
natural phenomenon it's a human
invention and we could have invented in
a lot of different ways we did invent it
in a lot of different ways our kind of
prevailing concept of justice a hundred
years ago is quite different for it is
today and let's have the humility to
admit that a hundred years from now we
will probably evolve significantly
further the fact that we have a record
of the trajectory of that evolution I'll
just sum justice but on on hundreds of
ethical questions that's a gift of
Judaism and to me personally out after
two meets it's a privilege to be a link
in that chain I want that I mean that's
that that's exciting to me so this is
why when you have three Jews at the
table you have four opinions that's a
hundred percent yes that's right it's
annoying so all right so all right
there's a lot to do there but let's just
go to the god part of that first because
because there is this interesting
phenomenon with with I think Jews
describing themselves as Jewish atheists
right and I think the average person
hearing that would go well how does that
make any sense how can you say you're a
member of a religion if you don't
believe in the basic tenets of the
reason like you could open up any Old
Testament or any book that they're gonna
have it any synagogue in anywhere it's a
lot about God so how can you be a Jew
and then not necessarily a believe be a
believer well so I I think the the
notion of God in even in Jewish
Scripture is actually quite fluid right
the it's it's not just some guy with a
beard who cares about what you eat right
we refer to that entity in the masculine
in the feminine in the singular and the
plural it's it's a very evolving
notion and as we get to kind of a
post-biblical era I think some of the
greatest Jewish sages of history have
questionable faith in the God of
Scripture Maimonides himself I'm not
convinced is a it is a true believer in
the god of Scripture as laid out in in
the Old Testament what I do think though
is there's a there's tremendous value in
having a reference point and to me the
notion and I think a lot of maybe more
devout people will take issue with it I
understand that and this is kind of part
of the debate that we have to have an
invented God can be just as meaningful
and as valuable certainly as a spiritual
rallying point as a revealed guy mm-hmm
and we can actually work together if
you're a true believer so to speak and
I'm not we can work out I've been
thinking in terms of a if you and I
start a business that makes circles
that's that's our product anybody can
come in and order a circle of any size
you just tell us the radius and we'll
make you your circle we need a point to
draw that circle circle around right and
we need a point in a radius that's it
now I could be of the view that we can
put that point on the ceiling on the
floor in space it doesn't matter it
really doesn't matter as long as we have
the radius and a point we can make the
circle you can be of the view that no
I'm sorry that this circle is not kosher
unless the point around which is drawn
is right in the middle of that wall we
can work together because okay so let's
do it I don't care where it goes you do
care where it goes let's put it where
you want it and that's fine as long as
and this is an exercise very much in
love and in humility as long as you're
okay with the idea that I think you're
crazy
that wall and I'm okay with you you
think I'm a heretic that that I I don't
I don't care the result is the same we
have our circle and we can work together
and in many ways I think that is that is
Judaism and if you know we've conflated
faith with religion in this country
because and that's a very Christian
notion it's not a Jewish notion we faith
is not really a critical part of Judaism
so does that explain why someone like
Albert Einstein who certainly you know
God doesn't play dice with the universe
who so he wasn't a believer in any sort
of traditional sense although maybe in
the the way that you were describing it
he was extremely proud of being Jewish
he was almost the president that he was
going to be the first president of
Israel and obviously he lived through
Germany during the ha'la'tha so or at
least was a child at the beginning of it
so that that type of person though seems
to exist there's a there's a lot of that
you go to hospitals in New York City
where they have like a Shabbat elevator
for doctors yeah and that seems very
strange and yet it's somehow kind of
function so that's just a piece of
everything that you're talking about
baby yeah I mean I I think you know it's
it sounds it sounds crazy but operating
system is a is is a better term to me it
captures Judaism better than religion
does yeah right it's a code through
which we yeah through which we're appart
or a lens for which we see the world we
don't have to see it the same way that's
okay yeah so so what about the cultural
and traditional part of it because most
Jew so I grew up in Long Island everyone
was either Jewish or Greek or Italian
basically but but sir a certain ethnic
identity that most of them came from
Ellis Island you know they were
grandparents one came from Ellis Island
eventually lived in Brooklyn or Queens
and then they made it to Long Island but
I grew up obviously around a lot of
Jewish people most people weren't
religious per se but there was a huge
cultural identity there's a sense of
humor mostly a sense of humor I would
say problem perhaps more than anything
else a certain way of talking to each
other a certain like Seinfeld II in way
of looking at the world right do you
think that is enough to sustain
something long enough no I think it's
great it's it's essential it's it's more
an outgrowth of the core than then core
itself but no it's not it's a you know
again we need to ask ourselves do we
want this people to continue existing if
we do we need a much more tangible much
more accessible much more definable a
source of identity than humor is
difficult to kind of put your finger on
I you may die and we know we both know
what we're talking about when we say
Jewish humor yeah we know we're talking
about we say Jewish thinking this is a
Jewish way of think of looking at a
problem we're like we get that but it
is a little bit too nuanced I think to
communicate to certainly to future
generations or to other people yeah
so what is it so what's needed then in
this vision of the future that you think
would be the right way to continue this
this incredible and also tragic story
what's the best way to write so the good
news is I see a path to making it not
tragic but still incredible and it is a
shift in our story right
but even that right there is a huge
party right it's sort of acknowledging
like it's a little bit weird to look
back at the history of our ancestors and
go man there was a lot of death here
there was a lot of horrible things that
happen and I talked about it many times
our family members on both sides that
died in the Holocaust right let family
members that live in Israel now I you
know that people that's it's a history
of pogroms and genocides and Holocaust
and all of these things that make it a
little bit tough to look at the future
or something like that yet look III hear
that I you know I have conflicting
feelings on using that history as a as
an anchor of identity even though many
of us do and for many of us it's still
relevant you know to be clear yeah
certainly Israel is changing that I
suppose well Zac it's weezy well so in
Israel you feel it right and Israel that
you you do feel that in a way that I
don't think you do in the United States
which is you're in the Middle East yeah
and our neighbors have not reconciled
themselves with the notion of Jewish
sovereignty and we see that and it might
be difficult to see from here especially
if you know it's you're not it's not
your day to day I understand that those
crazy greedy Jews want a country that's
about six miles wide it won't be a right
you know man right everybody's gonna
right yeah I mean if you kind of look at
if you it doesn't doesn't take a ton of
analysis but what are the other Jewish
options in the Middle East we have 7.2
million Jews in Israel where they
supposed to go back to bed Baghdad
Damascus Cairo were you supposed to go
the entire Middle East has been
ethnically cleansed of 100 percent of
its Jews a hundred percent here's one
guy in Egypt isn't there why I read
about that I like the one guy
he's gone did meet the guy I think the
guy that claimed he was a Jew auditor
right right
you know so you look at that and you bet
brother with the tragedy of that
assimilation that the Baghdady jewish
community is a thousand years older than
islam itself yeah and it's been
eradicated zero there is no formula for
existing as a Jew in the Middle East
outside of Israel it doesn't work I mean
that's the there are no exceptions to
that rule that that's clear enough and
when you live in Israel it's it you know
it I think it's something that that's
quite clear so we're not in a place
where we can escape that anymore
now or so or yet I think I'm an optimist
in terms of Israel's eventual acceptance
among the community of nations in the
Middle East again I think there's a lot
of reasons to think that's happening
right now that that's sort of a whole
other show yet about geopolitics I guess
than anything else you know I think
they've started to just accept wow these
guys are here and they're actually
giving us water and a whole bunch of
other yeah there's a lot we can do
together yeah agreed
so anyhow yeah you know I don't think we
can divorce ourselves completely from
our past nor should we I think that's
that's fine but as an anchor for
identity particularly in the United
States where you know the my children's
generation in this country sees the
Holocaust is kind of ancient history
that's not it has no bearing on their
lives you know they see themselves as
you know very very privileged you know
well educated you know Americans with
with a great future Americans and
Israelis with with a great future
wherever they end up in either country
you know they so selling them on Jewish
identity through the Holocaust or
through you know the Inquisition or
through you know that part of Jewish
history for now is not working and I
hope it continues not working right I
mean a lot of people have reacted to the
book by saying you know one good wave of
anti-semitism and we solve your your
problem so that's yeah I hope first off
let's look should we hope for that I
mean that doesn't sound like it's all so
pathetic notion what you that we can't
without anti-semites there can't be Jews
I mean that's that what there's so much
more to this legacy
and then hatred and persecution so much
more there's so much richness here and
beauty that we can develop and now steer
now that we have the agency to actually
steer ourselves let's do it let's go
this is a this is a it to me a very
exciting moment in Jewish history with
with a threat associated with it
obviously yeah it's interesting because
right now in America and you you
reference us a little bit earlier that
with what's going on with the left if
you were to ask me where anti-semitism
is in America right now are there some
KKK members that might be far-right
extremists yes there are and they've
always been here I don't think there's
any more of them I don't think they have
any institutional power I think the
media makes it seem like they're
everywhere and they're just not they
call everybody and not see I just don't
think that's real I don't I just simply
don't think it's real yeah where I am
concerned about anti-semitism though is
what is happening on the left that Jews
are no longer victims and they love
victimhood because they be few
victimhood as virtuous and now Jews are
thought of as white so my brown
brother-in-law Russians parents were
both refugees kicked out of their
countries is now privileged in the you
know it's he's a immigrant and her and
child of refugees and he's brown but
he's now privileged and I see a much
more what actually I think is systemic
racism because they're trying to build
this all into the system of how we view
each other I see that really hardening
on the left and and I think that's why
so many you know I talked about salt I'm
why I see minority groups breaking from
leftism I see this happening with with
black people there's a lot of evidence
that it's happening it's how I see it
happening with gay people I see it
happening with Jewish people I think
it's happening with Asian people now so
in a certain way I'm hopeful because
Jews are going ah the old thing maybe
isn't working the way it always has so I
I hope I'm not naive I'm I'm an optimist
on that as well in that I think the
ideologies that have you I think for
very natural and good reasons have
surfaced right we're always going to be
over shooting and undershooting truth
but that's that that's us you know human
beings are in many ways self-defeating
right intersectionality as an
exclusionary ideology versus as a as a
framework for understanding social
phenomena
I mean it's collapsing in the face of
Louis Farrakhan right
how are you supposed to be gay and still
be on board with this yeah how are you
supposed to be a Jew and still be on
board with this and I think I feel like
we're not even if you look at what to me
is a shame because you know Blacks and
Jews in this country have been kindred
spirits over a hundred years
you know we founded the n-double-a-cp
this was our fight yeah black education
that the schools in the south where
Jewish funders are we marched and died
in Mississippi yeah I was gonna say most
of those people in those pictures
marching with morning most of the white
people were Jewish yeah right so this is
a false divide which I think ultimately
corrects itself I was speaking to a
group recently about black lives matter
and you know to me this this ultimately
has to be self-correcting you you take
the people who really have been on your
side and have tied your fate to yours
and for some reason have decided that
they're on the other side right if you
look at the 2016 social policy agenda of
the black lives matter movement it has
one foreign policy clause it's to
condemn the genocide apartheid state of
Israel yeah site right for some reason
the Palestinian population keeps going
up this is the worst genocide right
we're terrible numbers yeah yeah but you
kind of look at that and if black lives
matter which they do to me you know my
wife and I adopted two Darfurian
refugees ten years ago in Israel they
live in Israel now there is a genocide
going on right now in Darfur between
300,000 and 400,000 people killed
because they are black the foreign
policy agenda that you chose in a
movement who flies the flag of black
lives is not that it's it's that I I
have to believe is ultimately gonna
collapse under the weight of its own did
just unreasonableness doesn't work
that's interesting though cuz I don't
see that as a tension between Blacks and
Jews cuz I really don't see that engine
I see it I see that as a tension between
what I would say basically are crazy
leftists verse everyone else pretty much
that just happens to be a political
slice I don't think that's really a
racial tension does that does that make
sense yeah no I hear that I mean I had
to put plenty of black interlocutors who
see it exactly as we do by the way who
also say kind of like we do
Judaism victimhood is a terrible basis
for identity
yeah self-defeating and it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy ultimately if
you let you know let lets aspire to
something better than that
yeah bothering not ignoring the past
right there is there it's a legacy here
that we we of course have to acknowledge
if we're going to if we're going to do
anything about it but does that also
explain the the endless sort of focused
hatred of Israel from the modern left
and I'm not just in America but in
virtually every country or the UN which
is basically the biggest croc in the
history of the world why they all you
know for every one condemnation of
another country there's 27 against
Israel or something right yeah
completely insane that Jews in Israel
are no longer victims and the left loves
victims so now that you're not victims
anymore you automatically are the enemy
I would argue it's better to not be a
victim and to be alive than to be liked
by a bunch of people who want you to
live like slaves but right but does that
is it really that simple to boil it down
because I think it's pretty close to
that look I I wish that were the best
explanation for it
I fear that anti-semitism it might be a
better a better explanation because
there are plenty of countries Singapore
is succeeding wildly incredible
Singapore is an incredible story there
are no UN resolutions against Singapore
that's not something that so well oh I
mean I mean the history of the Jews was
you guys were on the you were though on
the victim side of this whole thing and
we liked it out yeah we like it that way
that that's the way it was right and
there's some weird thing about like the
chosen people think about that it's like
ah see guess they're not that chosen or
something like that but my favorite line
ever writes from Fiddler on the Roof
which is you know I know we're the
chosen people I just wish we could be
chosen for something else right but but
so I don't mean that in terms of a
success of a country I think I mean the
uniqueness of a success of a country
that was so associated with being
slaughtered and everything else that no
longer acts as a victim that bat flips
the whole thing on its head
yeah like it could be that I mean I I
just see the the suspension of logic in
a lot of the condom nations of Israel
that I think you're talking about remind
me very much of the suspension of logic
in classic European anti-semitic tropes
right the blood libel things that don't
really make sense right that's uh it
rhymes with that and the fact that we're
this they're Jews in this case and Jews
in that case seat seems to be not a
coincidence
unfortunately I wished you know I and I
try to see different because it feels
like a cop-out to say oh it's
anti-semitism it it's tough for me to
find an explanation of it you know
things like you can't be a Zionist and a
feminist right you're gonna pick the
first liberal democracy to elect a
female head of state to say you can't be
that and a feminist estranged better
women's representation on corporate
boards and corporate management's than
the United States
that's the country that feminists can't
can't can't get them on board with when
it's neighborhood is exactly the
opposite of that remind me again are
they throwing gays off roofs in Israel
all right exactly yeah right I mean I
think tel aviv i forgot which mitch
magazine put it up number one gay city
on earth right it's how is it that you
know the spanish pride parade will
boycott Israeli marchers or the Chicago
Dyke March will throw people out for
having a Star of David I yeah these
things don't make sense and to me it
very much rhymes with a with something
from our from our history I think we're
at a place where we can I don't maybe
it's too much to say safely ignore it
but it doesn't have to factor into our
lives in any huge way in Israel you
don't feel that in your day-to-day you
don't feel embattled or you know you
know you know we're not glued to the TV
to watch you know UN votes and see what
happens with and okay that we know that
story
another troops obliterating that thing
anyways yeah true yeah that's right so
hopefully these are site you know cycles
that work themselves out but you know
again I kind of almost allergic to this
to anything that might lead us to define
ourselves on those terms let's not let
the haters define us we're in a place
where we have the agency to do it
ourselves and that that to me is the
that's the exciting part of this but
that's why I wrote the book so with all
this in mind one of the things that I'm
always amazed by is when they do that
Happiness index right that world
happiness index that comes out every
year Israel is usually
somewhere between like 10 and 15 on that
yeah and yet if you turn on CNN and all
you ever see your bombs blowing up and
terrorist attacks and buses blowing up
and all that now there obviously is some
connection to the good things that
you're talking about and the ability to
still be happy in a pretty rough part of
the world what do you see that as if you
believe in the premise that I'm offering
right well I mean you you've spent time
in Israel it's it is a happy place it's
not no Israeli surprise by those by
those rankings we don't we get it when
we and and I think there's a certain
appreciation of that yeah I think a big
piece of it is this community and you
know a part of why that the book is I
think getting the reception that it's
getting right now is there's a thirst
for for that in many ways we're losing
it maybe there's a pendulum that swings
kind of between you kind of think we can
see conceive of ourselves as individuals
we can conceive ourselves as cells in an
organism you know called community
religion country with it however you you
you choose to define it it seems that
we're kind of on an individualistic
extreme of the swing of that of that
pendulum today and there is a communal
itch that needs to get scratched I think
that's that that that's wired into us
right now and one of the things that
Israel is getting right and there are
many things that is what's getting wrong
is that as I described in the book one
of the things that Israel's getting
right is it is a community and a sense
of I have your back and you have mine we
have responsibility for each other
we're not just individuals in some rat
race we are that there we are part of
something bigger how do you think that
do you think is a Jewish Jewish ethnic
per se versus the fact that everyone has
to go to the army which would then would
obviously create a very similar ethic
yeah so I think they're both at play
it is a profoundly Jewish ethic though
kind of if you look at other diasporas
look what this Jewish community of the
United States did in the 70s and 80s on
behalf of Soviet Jewry right people that
hadn't met before people that they
hadn't had any association with for
generations but
felt that these are people we need to
stick our necks out for and write checks
for and March for and protest for and
get them out and look what Israeli jury
did right a population of four and a
half million people absorbed over a
million immigrants in a year and a half
it's a huge nut to swallow from a fiscal
perspective from a social and and did it
unquestioningly of course it was the
obvious thing we were gonna do we do
look out for each other and that is a
that is a Jewish notion look what we did
for a Yemeni jewelry and Ethiopian
jewelry and Iraqi jewelry we take
responsibility for each other so that is
a very Jewish ethic and it permeates
Israeli society you can feel that and
that's a that's part of it and yet and I
think part of it is through military
service right you you do get exposed in
a real many of us do at least in in a in
a frontal way to people who have
genocide intentions towards you luckily
they don't have the means to to fulfill
those those intentions but they're
pretty obvious I mean it's it's not
something you anybody who serves will
see that I don't think that so does that
make you happy I don't know it's
certainly fought for jazz a sense of
community I think yeah you have some
stories about combat yeah and and how
that relates yeah I mean you know one of
the things I try to talk about is you
know if we're gonna revive a Jewish
spark which you know I think two or
three generations of Jews in Israel and
the United States have tried to
extinguish in many ways what are the
starting points you know how are their
embers that we can play what do you mean
by that that two or three generations of
Jews have tried exchanger you mean just
sort of run from religion if you look at
its REI segment Israeli society and it's
my segmentation I just people have you
know issues with this specific
segmentation but I do see it and I think
a lot of people see it as well when we
look at the notion of Jewish statehood
there are three separate constituencies
in Israel that are defined in my view by
what their vision is for Jewish
statehood and these are visions that
were never reconciled they should have
been but but but they weren't instead in
1947 we came up with an agreement to
split them into different communities
and that's how we are in Israel today
there's a community that called the
secularists that really
I want a harbor a safe safe haven for
the Jews that is structured as a
democracy that's pretty much it that was
Herzl vision that's a Hobbes vision with
some Jewish trappings they have the
national holiday should be Jewish
holidays but but not much more than that
we're not gonna have the government
prescribed religious practice to the
citizenry that's that's the secularist
vision there's a theocratic vision which
had very few adherents in 1947 when the
status quo agreement which is the
agreement that cemented those
constituencies into no different camps
mm-hmm there are very few adherents with
almost no political ambitions today that
group is big and growing massively and
has maximalist political ambitions to
turn Israel into a theocracy and then
there's what I call a territorial is
vision which says the whole Land of
Israel is a is a god-given gift and we
there is no human prerogative in
relinquishing it we can't step away from
it
these are three competing camps in
Israeli society whose views were going
to have to reconcile when I talk about
extinguishing Judaism though it was the
secularists who ruled Israel certainly
until 1977 and and I would argue to a
great extent still to this day and the
original secularists were Russians right
the ark is the architects of Jewish
statehood were central Europeans right
Hungarians Austrians out Herzl hadam
Israel's angle that that crowd the
actual builders were Russians they were
the Eastern Europeans who are escaping
pogroms when they came to Israel and
these guys came at the dawn of
Bolshevism and the Czar was their enemy
and you know the Bolshevik Revolution
was largely Jewish from the leadership
down to the to the to the to the ground
troops anti-semitism is so embedded in
Russia that it became very very quickly
clear as Trotsky understood too late
we're still the Jews and we're out
welcome in this enterprise but people
who have had drunk that socialist
kool-aid came to Israel and stand and
that was the elite of our country for
the first you know 50 years of its
existence and certainly pre-state right
the kyboot snakes
the guys who taught me to be in israeli
right the the guys I was with at the
academy were primarily kyboots
that was that was Israel's elite so they
were like small-scale socialists at some
level either was when I'd spend weekends
on you know my friends keep with same
and there was a commissar that was the
title Nicky boots
I don't know how small-scale this was a
that that that ethic has has more or
less died but what's what's interesting
is there was a baby that was thrown out
with the bathwater when they came to
Israel is that these people fanatical
about expunging any vestige of a
European anti-semitic stereotype in
Israel we were gonna be muscular and
feisty well and we're not gonna lock
ourselves in a fetter studying Talmud or
anything like that we're gonna be out in
the fields farming and fighting and
defending our land was it and in many
ways I think was an abrogation of many
things that are Jewish by the way you
can be both right and you can stand up
for yourself and also study you can do
both one of the stories I tell in the
book is kind of interesting as my first
I you know I did nothing Jewish growing
up except for fasting on Yom Kippur
whatever reason it was kind of an easy
thing to understand where Jews we fast
on Yom Kippur that's our thing yeah I
did nothing else I was that but I did
that and it was kind of another
challenge I don't know what it was but
that was the first time I didn't fasten
you know Cooper was my first Yom Kippur
at the Academy where was a feast it was
a feast a new keyboard the kyboot snakes
you know made I write in the book you
know a grilled cheese sandwiches was the
thing which was really ham and cheese so
yeah I didn't want to shock anybody but
Wow so they so you illustrate that point
meaning that they were really going out
of their way to erase any connection as
religion even though they had come to a
country to be safe because they were
persecuted for their religion I mean
there's like real psychological stuff
and here's the interesting irony is it
was a very unknownst attempt to erase
that history Yom Kippur was still an
anchor point it was a day of rebellion
against our ancestors so we were still
orbiting the same death star so to speak
we're just in the opposite orbit we
hadn't gone off into space which is
actually really good news if you want to
rekindle a Judaism and and I think a lot
of the ethic of the Israel Defense
Forces
is Jewish despite itself and you know so
one of the you know to toward the when I
started flying in reserves was a very
kind of ethically fraught period in
fruit fruit for the Air Force in Israel
and and these are dilemmas that now you
know my colleagues in the US Air Force
and Navy face and then the British air
for we're all facing these today which
is how do you fight a war in civilian
areas when your enemy can dictate
exactly where that Wars gonna be fought
if you're launching rockets out of
schools and hospitals at civilian
targets how are you supposed to contend
with with that challenge and it's tough
and I know there are no perfect answer
to that but you know what one of the
stories we talk about is is there was a
Hamas planner named Salah Shehadeh who
had been responsible for really hundreds
of civilian deaths in Israel there was a
kind of a wave of bus bombings primarily
bus bombings but also restaurants cafes
this is like late 90s this is early
2000s and we call the second second okay
Second Intifada back exactly and we had
tried to target this guy a number of
times and our rules of engagement were
clear enough to the enemies is that
Ayana right it was a very kind of a
cat-and-mouse game as we kind of got
more nuanced in in in in finessing the
rules of engagement it only took a few
weeks for the other side was whether it
was his below in Lebanon or Hamas in
Gaza to understand how close could we
bomb to civilian targets how close could
we bombed two UN facilities what types
of munitions we could use in these
situation just kind of very clear and
and we tipped our hand in in many ways I
think maybe so when we see this out of
the media out during the war that Israel
has bombed all of this stuff and they
show you all this destruction you're
really missing the subtext I mean I
think a certain amount of people I try
to tweet about it at least is show that
you know they dropped they dropped
leaflets saying you guys got to get out
of this house because there's people you
know text messages text message our me
in the history of the world would do
anything like this ever
the Israelis keep doing it and there and
as you're saying their enemies actually
take advantage over intentionally they
which is now they put bombs in hospitals
right and they say well what are you
going to do knowing
that the world will be more than happy
to have the Jews right by the way which
to me is okay to ignore it's okay to
ignore we need to defend ourselves and
you know you mean ignore the media
outrage yeah yeah me yes it's it's there
and I think we sometimes pay a little
bit too much attention to it
these same critics weren't doing much
when we were being exterminated right
now that we're defending ourselves we're
gonna not take their advice what we're
gonna do this the way we want to do it
ethically ethically but not to appease a
European critic or the UN or anything
like that but to do this Jewishly right
and there is a way to do it and it's not
clean and it's not simple and these
dilemmas are real and you're not gonna
solve them in any perfect way so you
know the you get the kind of frustration
of not being able to get this guy and
watching buses blow up children killed
over and over again with his
fingerprints on each of these it was a
very tough thing to go we finally got a
shot at him there was an intelligence
failure and we hit the house that he was
in it was on the outskirts of Gaza City
but 14 people were there and wouldn't
that we'd and nine of them were
civilians and Israel erupted and
outraged and this is not the European we
don't need the UN and the Europeans to
tell us when there's no problem right
yeah to class-action lawsuits against
the Israeli Air Force by Jewish Israeli
civil rights groups 27 pilots quitting
right it was the kind of famous the
pilots letter which were kind of the
open letter published in the newspaper
saying we're stepping down from active
service and this became a morale crisis
in the Air Force and the way we
addressed it and and this to me is is
sort of the connections why these
stories are in there is down hollow - at
the time was was the commander of chief
of the Air Force did a tour of the
various bases and wings of the Air Force
to do a debriefing debriefing as a
almost a religious ritual in the Israeli
Air Force is it's a very very rigorous
painful methodical kind of a very
Talmudic exercise of go
through everything that went wrong some
of the things that went right but mainly
went went wrong and and how do we how do
we improve and it's a ranked blind and
he put himself out there and he came to
our the wing that conducted the
operation so he started with us and
there were about 50 people in the room
and we had an almost all-night session
which started with his debriefing but
but progressed very quickly into a kind
of an ethical debate as to how do we
conduct ourselves and the way I
described it which I think some of my
colleagues who read it think and think
it was pretty accurate it was 2002 so
some time has passed a friend of mine
from the US Navy read and said what you
guys conducted would be mutiny in in our
organization and I understand that I
understand it because it was a complete
subversion of the hierarchy in pursuit
of a truth and ethical truth which is
elusive but it is a very Jewish way to
to to conduct yourself it's not
hierarchical it is a crowds wisdom that
is guiding us and that doesn't mean
you're going to get perfect answers and
our answers have not been perfect since
then but they've improved and and and
we're also it provided real clarity on
how we navigate this dilemma what do we
define as Optima right you can't on the
one hand please the virtue of truth and
tell the bride that she's ugly and at
the same time the virtue of humanity
you're gonna have to navigate Optima and
that's life right and again it's a very
Jewish exercise and it's how we conduct
ourselves to say that we solved them
that we solved it but this is this is
the way we muddle through in Judaism and
to me that there's value in that it was
not extinguished by our socialist
founders yeah so it's interesting that
you said that that we should just ignore
or that Israelis should just ignore the
media portion of this because that
always seems to be a huge part of any of
this in the Middle East at any time it's
like oh every it there's just like this
endless focus on this absurdly tiny
piece of land with no virtually no
natural resources I guess they found
natural gas in the last ten years but
for most of their history had no it
certainly had no oil dislike obsessive
focus where it's like they're just kind
of living and going
and doing their thing and I guess maybe
we should all probably pay less
attention to the media I think that's
popular news aren't doing a great job of
controlling the media I guess that's
right that's right
yeah we've lost control of the media
that's that's the bigger problem here by
the way to be clear we joke I have a
Palestinian business partner I'm a
co-owner and a Palestinian business we
joke about this the Palestinians get
this as well by the way I and I think my
partner's it was today's is a close
friend I think also sees it as part of
the Palestinian problem is that you know
I'm a I'm a pro Palestine guy I'd love
to see a Palestinian state tomorrow
mm-hmm the challenge for the Palestinian
is very much the same as it is our
challenge is they need to define
themselves in a framework that is
something other than victimhood hmm take
away the Jews what are the Palestinians
exactly that you know if they continue
to define themselves with us as the
backdrop they're never going to be
anybody and there's so much potential to
build something exciting in Palestine
and in many ways when we talk about the
media maybe it's it's too strong a term
we should ignore it we're all complicit
in that in perpetuating that human
failure in the Middle East were
complicit in it we're placing no demands
on the Arab world to take some sort of
responsibility for its future it's so
easy to say oh it's it's the Jews fault
you know over and over again at some
point that rings hollow in Israel so we
start ignoring it in the Arab world you
know if you're if you it's it's a very
intoxicating notion right as if someone
sells you victimhood
it's something that's kind of easy to
embrace but at the end of the day it's
toxic you you should steer away from
yeah and interestingly I think that does
ring back to the way you were defining
sort of an old anti-semitism that's now
thrust on Israel because Egypt can bomb
the hell out of the border of Gaza and
blow up tunnels and do whatever they
want no one cares right Saudi Arabia can
bomb the hell out of Yemen and kill
thousands and thousands of people in
causes of famine and nobody cares
genocide in Darfur yeah and and so
there's this odd asymmetry there well
there's an asymmetry there's a literal
asymmetry and the powers of both sides
which
being used against each other and then
there's an asymmetry of media and
everything else so it does have that
that one through line that these yeah
these weird people kind of survived
through this thing and look look who the
who the real victims are right they're
black Sudanese they're Yemeni civilians
they're Iraqi civilians they're Syrian
civil
these are the real victims good they're
not getting attention right we're not no
no um resolutions coming in lately on
Darfur or anything we're very focused on
a problem that I don't think it's is a
huge problem in fact we probably
contributing more to its perpetuation
and it's its solution yeah all right so
let's finish with with some of the the
future of how this stuff can work out I
have a sense of how you think it can
work out on the Israeli side they just
have to sort of keep going basically I
think and and and sort of reconcile I
think what you think those three
different pillars by society are that
which is not easy I know yeah would you
say that's a bigger problem for them
than the external pressures much much
bigger yeah in fact it's the only thing
I'm really frightened of in Israel I
don't think the Palestinian issue sinks
us I don't think the Iranians sink us I
don't think the greater Middle East
thing says we sink ourselves I think the
good news is it's the same medicine in
Israel in the United States it's it's
got to be about Judaism we didn't come
to start a Jewish state just to have
another democracy in the world this is
the Jewish state it's the nation-state
of the Jews what does that mean for Dave
Rubin who's not a citizen of that state
but is a Jew we are that his
self-proclaimed nation-state what does
that mean what's our responsibility to
him these are questions that we haven't
really answered and they're not just
Israeli questions they're they're Jewish
questions so ultimately I think we're
all engaged Israeli American and rest of
world Jewry in the same exercise which
is good news because we don't have you
know a dozen different prescriptions
it's one it's one the exercise is we
need to define Judaism for the 21st
century what does that mean exactly
who's in who's out how do you get in how
do you leave and what I don't actually
put down a definition for Judaism I put
down a mechanism because the definition
should evolve it should be static
whatever I say today is probably wrong
to start with but certainly will be
wrong you know ten years from now what's
important is that we
a mechanism for continuing to refine and
and hone our the definition of what
Jewish is and that the last section of
the book is exactly that I'll leave it
as a surprise cuz I ah because you wrote
a book I got it well it's been a
pleasure chatting with you I think this
is a really fascinating thing because it
permeates so many of the issues that I
talked about just related because this
is related to free speech it's related
to oppression and perceived oppression
and freedom and liberty and all of these
things in history and the rest of it so
I thoroughly enjoyed this so thanks for
coming this same thank you for more on
Tala you can follow him on Twitter
although you're not a big Twitter know
you know Facebook that's wrong generator
that's why you got a big smile that
often you can follow them on Twitter
it's t Kenan
[Music]